una declaración excepcional que tomó a
todos por sorpresa hoy en alemania 3 una
reunión de emergencia con los 16 líderes
regionales la canciller alemana angela
merkel echó para atrás una de las
principales decisiones que habían tomado
así apenas pocos días para luchar contra
la tercera ola de coronavirus aquí en
alemania la decisión de imponer
restricciones más estrictas durante los
días de semana santa para evitar más
contactos para evitar más contagios una
decisión que admitió la canciller angela
merkel era difícil de aplicar en el
plazo previsto una decisión también que
estaba siendo criticada ampliamente aquí
en alemania y estaba generando
incertidumbre entre la población
la declaración sorpresiva de merkel está
generando todo tipo de reacciones aquí
en alemania desde quienes apoyan a la
canciller por considerar que es un acto
valiente pedir disculpas públicas hasta
quienes creen que esa declaración es un
ejemplo de como merkel está perdiendo
cada vez más y más poder de cualquier
manera es probable que este discurso de
merkel este miércoles en berlín pase a
la historia como uno de sus más
memorables en sus 15 años de gobierno en
momentos en que alemania tiene amplias
dificultades para luchar contra el
conavi
en momentos en que hay un crecimiento
exponencial de casos en que hay
problemas con el programa de vacunación
y también en momentos en que el país se
está preparando para las elecciones
federales de septiembre que decidirán
quién será el sucesor de angela mente